the pandemic has seen hospitals
everywhere filling up forcing many
people to postpone other medical
procedures
but one procedure in particular has been
booming
cosmetic surgery
with many people in lockdown unable to
leave their homes why are they going
under the knife to improve their
appearance
welcome to the covert 19 special i'm
rebecca ritters well it may seem
counter-intuitive but it's true in many
parts of the world the rate of plastic
surgery as well as other non-surgical
aesthetic treatments such as botox has
been soaring during the pandemic and
lockdown measures limited people's
contact with each other it seems many
have become more self-conscious about
the times they are being seen
tanya chang has undergone buttocks
treatment on her face
she did it during taiwan's lockdown when
she wouldn't come into contact with
other people for her it was a rare
opportunity
i'm in sales and i have to face clients
every day at work
it would be very inconvenient to have
bruises and swelling on my face after a
treatment
now that everyone wears a mask i don't
need to worry about that
so i am taking advantage of the pandemic
but that's just one of the reasons for
what has been a big boom in cosmetic
procedures all over the world
dermatologists in the us reported a
nearly 60 percent rise in patients
seeking aesthetic treatment since the
pandemic began
taking part in video conferences has
become routine for many people
and they have become conscious of
wrinkles and blemishes
ultimately people also want to look good
on screen
for more i'm joined by tony piku she's a
clinical psychologist from melbourne
australia which also happens to be my
hometown tony lovely to have you on the
program tell us why is cosmetic surgery
increasing during the pandemic it seems
counterintuitive
i think there are so many reasons behind
it part of it is definitely because of
lockdowns and the fact that people
couldn't access cosmetic procedures and
we know when something's forbidden and
we're not allowed it makes us want it
more
but i think as well as that people are
spending so much more time on videos
looking at themselves being able to
scrutinize their appearance and also on
social media
with not much else to do i guess while
we're stuck at home for a lot of the
time during the pandemic and that's
causing a lot more body dissatisfaction
and we're also seeing a lot more of
cosmetic surgeries available on on
social media and people publicizing it
so i think that's been a large part
it seems to be a lot more young people
which is also i would have thought
counter-intuitive and we know obviously
people do it for the aging process but
why is it mainly young people that are
seeking treatment now
yeah well i think touching on the fact
that social media has played such a big
role in this uptick in interest in
cosmetic procedures during the pandemic
we know that young people in particular
live
a lot of their lives online
and when they're spending so much time
on social media it's often promoting
this sometimes distorted or unrealistic
standard of beauty that they're then
trying to attain
and again they're they're exposed to it
they're exposed to all these cosmetic
procedures people videoing and filming
their surgeries and putting them online
and i think that's
increasing their interest in getting it
done but also we have people who had
more disposable income available to them
during the pandemic because they weren't
spending it necessarily on travel or
leisure and so now they've got this
money lying around that they can then
put towards a cosmetic surgery that they
might not have been able to afford
previously
what kind of global trends are we seeing
is this something that's happening more
in the west or you know is it really
popular in the us or australia or you
know what are the trends you're seeing
there
yeah i think we've seen it happening
around the world i've seen lots of
research and articles popping up from
across the globe everyone reporting
increased interest in cosmetic
procedures
and those are invasive and non-invasive
as well so we still see that the most
popular are the non-invasive procedures
like the botox and the dermal fillets
but during the pandemic there's also
been a massive increase in
body contouring so things like the
liposuction and tummy tuck i think
because as people's bodies might have
been changing during the pandemic
they're becoming more self-conscious and
wanting to get some of those procedures
done as well
i've also seen lots of pages on social
media on instagram for instance
debunking the before and after photos
and that kind of thing do you think
there could be a pendulum swing the
other way sort of anti-an anti-plastic
surgery wave on social media as well
if there is one it's definitely a lot
quieter unless we definitely don't see
it as much
um but i think there is you know there's
a growing wave of body positivity
influences people who are promoting body
acceptance and from time to time they
will post images like that showing the
editing of photos and the setting up of
before and after photos which i think
does help to give people a bit more of a
critical lens of what they might be
seeing on social media
people are kind of relying on these
regular beauty treatments to boost
self-esteem but do they actually help
psychologically are they beneficial do
people feel better after having uh
plastic surgery
yeah it's a great question and for the
vast majority of people they really do
so the research tells us that about 80
of people who get cosmetic procedures or
surgeries done are really happy with the
results and they report that you know
they feel better about that particular
body part that they had treated
and that it can boost their self-esteem
the thing is though that there's another
20 of people
who might be less satisfied with the
results and sometimes even experience
negative outcomes and they're usually
people like younger adults so those in
like their early 20s or even in their
teens getting cosmetic procedures done
and also people with significant mental
health issues and particular body body
dysmorphic disorder where they might not
have an accurate perception of what they
really look like
and so for those people they actually
tend to not do so well with cosmetic
procedures and they don't report the
same benefits
but for a lot of people they do find
that it boosts their self-esteem
and so just before we finish up do you
think there's a direct link between
covert 19 and the rise in plastic
surgery or is it just a coincidence and
social media
no i think that definitely video calls
video calls were something that we might
have done time to time before the
pandemic but that's been a huge part of
our lives just because of covid and i
think we're definitely seeing the zoom
boom or zoom dysmorphia rising that's
leading to that greater interest in
cosmetic procedures and also people are
struggling a lot more mentally and we
know when they're more anxious or more
depressed that that can also lead to
more body image concerns and so i think
those things are very uniquely because
of the covert 19 pandemic at the moment
that we've seen this increase in
interest in cosmetic surgery as well
all right clinical psychologist tony
picku speaking to us from melbourne
australia thanks very much
so how long could the cosmetic surgery
boom go on for here's our science
correspondent derek williams to answer
one of your questions
how long do most pandemics last
to make any predictions about how the
covet
pandemic could end it makes sense
to look at past pandemics and since they
provide data that could potentially help
us predict
how long the current one might last
experts trying to do that
tend to focus on the four officially
recognized respiratory disease pandemics
that have occurred in the last hundred
years which were all driven by an old
enemy of humanity
influenza
the most recent one was in 2009 when a
novel flu strain commonly called the
swine flu
swept the globe infecting by some
estimates up to one
in five people on the planet uh top-end
guesses say it might have caused close
to 600 000 deaths
in the 14 or so months that it raged the
swine flu pandemic was shorter
than a flu pandemic in in 1968 often
called um the hong kong flu
it was caused by a strain that killed at
least a million people worldwide
possibly many more all in all it lasted
a little less than two years
a decade before that a strain that
became widely known as the asian flu
killed a similar number of people in in
the late 1950s now what was really
interesting about that pandemic
was that it was the first where vaccines
played a key role it's thought that
their quick development and distribution
saved potentially hundreds of thousands
of lives
finally
there was the granddaddy of all modern
flu pandemics the one that devastated
the planet at the end of the first world
war
starting in around 1918.
it's viewed
as the most severe pandemic in recent
history that flu strain infected we
think around a third of the world's
population and killed at least 50
million people over the course of around
uh three years so
to sum it up
those recent pandemics lasted between
around a year and and three years but
they were of course caused by flu
viruses not coronaviruses so
so trying to draw parallels with the
current pandemic experts say
is a tenuous move at best
[Music]
and finally classical music has a long
history here in germany but the pandemic
has made it difficult to stage concerts
so one orchestra in the city of dresden
treated music lovers to a different kind
of symphony take a look
[Applause]
a concert like no other
the banks of the elba river played host
to a most unusual melody
[Music]
a steamboat symphony
[Music]
german engineering with a baroque twist
a noteworthy experience for the audience
i'm here because i think the project is
great it's extraordinary and after this
period of covet 19 which isn't over it's
finally a little glimmer of hope and
it's good for the heart and the soul
[Music]
a chance to blow off some steam
while social distancing
[Music]
well that's our show for today if you'd
like more on any of our stories you'll
find that and much more on our website
dw.com forward slash covert19 we'll be
back at the same time next week hope you
can join us then thanks for watching